okay we're talking with Gerard in
Springfield Illinois 19 years old his
grandfather just passed away the family
farm is gonna be sold and he'll be
receiving about two million dollars and
he's wanting to know I never had more
than three thousand dollars what to do
with that is that a fair summary what
you told me so far sir yes sir okay I
think I hear wisdom in your voice in
that this money scares you a little bit
well absolutely
good I had some ideas and I didn't know
go ahead we'll find okay here's what we
want to do here's one right quick couple
things number one never invest or do
anything with money the rest of your
life in anything you do not understand
and that means that you're going to have
to understand things more in the coming
years than you do now but for right now
you keep it very very very simple number
two the Bible says in the in the
multitude of counsel there is wisdom and
so I would recommend that you build a
personal board of directors a financial
advisor a tax advisor a real estate
person a attorney a CPA five six things
around the area of money someone in the
insurance world and in each they don't
have to meet together with you but
they're your go-to guy or gal for
insurance your go-to guy for investment
advice your go-to person for real estate
your go-to person for a tax question you
see what I'm saying and every one of
these people you develop a relationship
with them and they must have the heart
of a teacher because you don't invest in
anything you don't understand okay and
over time that group of men and women
around you become your confidants and
they can advise you you don't
necessarily do what they say but they're
there to
teach you out of their area of expertise
and then you take your time
and you invest in things and you give
and you invest and you purchase almost
nothing I would purchase all most
nothing just keep living your life like
a 19 year old and think about investing
maybe enjoying a tiny amount of the
money but a very tiny amount you because
people start once you start spending
it's a thread on a sweater and you're
gonna unravel the whole thing spending
will be your enemy so you need to be on
a budget you need to be working and have
a career you support yourself and you
leave this money alone and you let it
grow and you give it and you invest it
and you enjoy a tiny percentage of it as
it goes along